[Música]
en Turquía hoy celebran los seguidores
del presidente ahí verdogana quien
entrara en su tercera década de mandato
tras vencer al opositora de qué mal
equidistaroglu en el balotaje de este
domingo las cuentas se quedaron con el
52,2% para el mandatario frente a 47,8
vamos al análisis con Jorge araneda él
Es doctor en relaciones internacionales
de medio oriente de la Universidad de
ankara en Turquía Muchas gracias a usted
buen día
muy buenos días y gracias por la
invitación Jorge una de las grandes
Preocupaciones en adelante tiene que ver
con la situación económica del país Cuál
es el paso a seguir para dar o intentar
dar estabilidad a la población y
hablemos de la lira que tras la victoria
de erdoganse debilitó frente al dólar en
las primeras operaciones europeas
particularmente
tanto si ganaba la el oficialismo o la
oposición uno de los grandes puntos no
solamente en términos externos sino
también en términos internos tiene que
ver con la economía tenemos una
inflación que crece a pasos agigantados
y por otra parte el Banco Central
completamente intervenido
a los últimos años por el El Ejecutivo
no han logrado tener una política
macroeconómica que lo lleve a algún tipo
de equilibrio y hoy en día incluso
semanas o días antes de la segunda
vuelta ya la reserva nacionales estaban
por debajo de los mínimos algunos
históricos en torno al su reservas de
oro y particularmente de dólares por lo
tanto se encuentra una situación
bastante precaria y que por otra parte
si uno toma las palabras del reelecto
presidente en donde plantea de que no
pedirá apoyo
al fondo internacional Bueno a un fondo
monetario internacional sino que acudirá
a sus aliados sobre todo del Golfo para
requerir liquidez en contra Cómo se
llama de esta escalada del dólar que ya
lleva casi lógicamente un año sin parar
es una situación bastante preocupante
mire rápidamente Rusia se dijo feliz por
erdogan china también lo felicitó y
estamos a la espera de una llamada del
presidente Joe biden de Estados Unidos
qué pasará en el plano de las relaciones
exteriores Usted cree que algo cambiará
de Cara a esta tercera década
particularmente No creo que algo cambie
sino lo que desde el punto de vista de
relación internacional es lo que vamos a
ver es una consolidación una
consolidación Por una parte de una
narrativa tanto nacional como extranjera
en términos de una presencia de Turquía
como una potencia media o una potencia
regional que quiere participar como un
actor clave pero también decisivo en lo
que tiene que ver con los conflictos que
algunos de ellos tienen intereses
lógicamente el gobierno de ankara
particularmente en lo que tiene que ver
con las aguas territoriales del
Mediterráneo lo que tiene que ver con
particularmente con sus relaciones
internacionales con Grecia
y por otra parte lo que tiene que ver
con sus acuerdos económicos en términos
de explotación de gas y petróleo con el
gobierno de Sisi en Egipto con su
presencia en Libia con las celebraciones
que anoche veíamos en Siria y
particularmente en Jerusalén por lo
tanto lo que veremos es una
consolidación de su presencia desde Asia
central con su acuerdo por el caspio
hasta los balcanes y también quizás una
mayor presencia de El díanet o el
Ministerio o o subsecretaría
particularmente como lo veríamos
nosotros de asuntos religiosos que tiene
una enorme presencia no solamente
internacional a través de sus
diplomaturas sino también nacional
produciendo y generando lógicamente una
narrativa
neoislamista y de un pasado lógicamente
otomano como nos esperaba menos la
oposición de Turquía entre tanto Jorge
se quedó corta por dos millones de votos
Quiero preguntarle que quedará Y si en
efecto serán días difíciles como dice
kiristároglu qué va a pasar con la
oposición
particularmente la oposición quedó
moralmente bastante
destruida
los partidos tendrán la mesa de los seis
tendrá que particularmente tener un
camino cuesta arriba si lo queremos
poner en esas palabras en términos de
lograr mantener una unidad Pero por otro
lado y algo que la oposición logró en
cierto medida darse cuenta fue que no
logró penetrar en el centro y en el
norte del país de hecho regiones del
centro
chanliurfaga se antepélix y otras
regiones arrasó el voto del oficialismo
con casi o mayor de un 70% Y eso tiene
que ver con una narrativa en donde el
país particularmente quedó quebrado por
una parte celeste con mayoría curva y el
oeste en ciudades Cómo se llama donde se
concentra el poder económico y
empresarial pero un centro y un Norte
estemi urbano donde la narrativa de la
oposición particularmente en el campo en
las zonas más conservadores no logró
penetrar Por otra parte y quizás una
crítica que la oposición va a tener que
evaluar tiene que ver particularmente
con que no se registró una mayor
participación en la segunda vuelta
dependiendo de Qué son estemos hablando
de dentro de Turquía tenemos una baja de
la participación entre un uno punto ocho
hasta un tres por ciento Y eso significa
que el voto necesario que necesitaba
arrastrar la oposición para lograr
cerrar esa brecha No lo logró y ahí es
donde lógicamente la mayoría de Turquía
en esta última elecciones votó por la
continuidad y no por el cambio
bueno eso Es evidente Pero además Es
evidente que erdogane tiene un desgaste
importante muy rápidamente porque nos
quedan solo unos segundos Cuál fue el
punto para usted decisorio en los
votantes
particularmente yo creo que hay que
entender esto en términos de los veinte
años no es un tema mucho más complejo
para para explicarlo pero lo que lo que
se dice Tiene que comprender que hay una
red una red de una base política en
donde los votantes hicieron un voto
racional en términos de qué nos presenta
el cambio que nos presenta la oposición
en términos de reforma económicas en
términos salariales en términos de
protección en términos donde es el
partido el que llega a las poblaciones
no solamente con beneficio o bonos sino
también como ha cambiado Turquía los los
últimos 20 años en donde las personas
han visto llegar universidades becas y
beneficios estatales que lógicamente no
tiene la cara del Estado tienen la cara
del partido del gobierno
y es la que p el que lógicamente logró
mantener esa continuidad pues mire
Muchísimas gracias Es Jorge araneda
doctor en relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad de ankara que tenga un
feliz día
un excelente jornada Y gracias por la
invitación nosotros continuaremos
informándoles a ustedes sobre las
noticias top a lo largo de este programa
quédense con nosotros y ya volvemos
[Música]